well the qurani app is about to show you
your progress with your soul
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
i hope you guys are well inshaallah
salaam alaikum so guys i'm just going to
keep it very short
and simple i'm out again my family and
this stuff come up so i have to jump on
inshallah
so yeah as you can see what conor
mcgregor said about habib's father
uh i mean allah says in the quran we do
not guide the sinning people
when people transgress all the time the
rights of others
they do nothing but humiliate themselves
and show their true colors you know and
when somebody can't intellectually
attack you they always
insult you and that's exactly what they
do with the prophet peace be upon him so
look at the way khabib's father ended
his journey in life
by saying he forgives connor and look
what kona does after his
uh khabib's father's death so it shows
you
how honorable khabib and his family is
and what kind of wretched disgusting
vile
coward this little corner is
so that's it brother sisters and yeah
and i in the quran allah does not guide
the sinning people who
carry on oppressing and doing things
like this
so it's just a reminder and may allah
a true legend um you know he smashed him
uh into pieces so as you can see guys
i'm going to keep out that inshallah i'm
not going to keep it that long
but yeah i'm on the go i'll be doing
videos on the go inshallah
and hope you guys benefited from this
and subhanallah protect
us you know um from being such
dishonorable
people like this that we have no respect
for the dead
or the life or those who are alive come
together muslim mate once again
to get clean water families in gaza 105
pounds can provide
interrupted water to two families for an
entire year